so the rise of the delta variant and a
slowdown in vaccinations is what's
driving this new mask mandate
the cdc has required mask wearing in
indoor areas regardless of your
vaccination status
in areas that are deemed as hot spots
and we're a hot spot in clark county so
today those rules went into effect
madison kimbrough spoke with locals to
see how they're feeling about wearing
masks again
she joins us now live madison
you know with so many people divided on
this issue the majority of people that
we spoke to were all for this reinstated
mass
mandate many voicing that the initial
mass mandate that we had
earlier this year was lifted too soon i
don't even mind it because
i think everyone should have been
wearing masks anyway because there's a
lot of people that are against getting
vaccinated
and it's best just to keep each other
safe to mask or not to mask
that is no longer the question as an
official mask mandate has been put in
place starting today
this comes after the cdc's new guideline
that everyone including fully vaccinated
people
need to wear a face covering while
indoors
well i mean it's back it's back you know
if you want to go about your business
just just wear them you know
as we have seen coveted numbers rise
here in las vegas our city
has become a hot spot destination for
the virus
many states telling people to stay away
from sin city and fear that they will
bring the virus back with them
while the majority of people we spoke to
were for mask wearing
we did hear from the opposing side i
just think a bunch of nonsense on both
sides because it's a lot of hearsay
whether you know people are pro or
against it
it's just no one really knows what's
really going on other than what we're
being told
as for the vaccine residents like
brittany huntington were hesitant
but now with the new delta variant in
play she believes it's the best option
but i'm more willing to do it now
because things are starting to kind of
like you said progress things are
developing a little stronger so it's
like
the vaccine you know it's better to get
it
again mass must be worn indoors in the
state of nevada and the cdc
also recommends that if you want to wear
a mask outside please do so
in large gatherings reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news
now